since its debut in 1989 The Simpsons has
broadcast over 600 episodes 1 more than
two dozen Emmys and a Peabody Award and
sold millions of dollars worth of
merchandise
it's a pop-culture juggernaut which
means that there's a small fortune of
lore and behind-the-scenes trivia out
there about Springfield's first family
pretty much the only adult Bart Simpson
actually respects his kids TV show hosts
Krusty the Klown when Matt graining and
his writing staff were developing the
show early on however someone floated
the concept that Krusty and Homer were
actually going to be the same person as
graining told Entertainment Weekly the
original idea behind Krusty the Klown
was that he was Homer in disguise but
Homer still couldn't get any respect
from his son who worshiped Krusty
unfortunately it became too complicated
a plot detail to work out once the show
was really getting off the ground so the
idea was abandoned but vestiges of the
Ark remained Krusty and Homer have an
almost identical character design Krusty
just has different hair and clown paints
and they're both voiced by the same
actor later on the sixth season episode
homey the clown references the original
idea and features Homer becoming a
Krusty the Klown impersonator
Wow I'm sorry I doubted you before dad
if there has to be a bastardized version
of Krusty I'm glad you The Simpsons
rivalry with President George HW Bush
goes back a lot further than the
neighborhood dispute which erupts in
1996's too bad neighbors in a 1990
interview with people then first lady
barbara Bush dismissed the show saying
it was the dumbest thing I had ever seen
in response the show's writers under the
guise of March Simpson sent mrs. Bush a
letter defending the show Marge wrote I
recently read your criticism of my
family I was deeply hurt heaven knows
were far from perfect and if truth be
known maybe just a wee bit short of
normal but as dr. Seuss says a person is
a person Barbara apologized but things
didn't end there early in his 1992
re-election campaign President Bush told
the convention of National Religious
broadcasters we are going to keep on
trying to strengthen the American family
to make American families a lot more
like the Waltons and a lot less like The
Simpsons
a subsequent episode of The Simpsons
featured the family watching a clip of
Bush's speech hey just like
we're praying for an end to the
depression - in the season three episode
stark-raving dad homer is mistakenly
sent to a psychiatric institution where
he's befriended by a hulking balding
patient named Leon who identifies
himself as Michael Jackson he certainly
had the voice of Michael Jackson because
the real King of Pop lent his voice to
the character who are you hi I'm Michael
Jackson for the Jacksons I'm Homer
Simpson from The Simpsons in the credits
however he was billed under the name
John J Smith so how did a relatively new
TV series land the biggest pop star in
the world
Jackson simply phoned up and asked a fan
of the show Jackson at first wanted to
play himself but eventually went with
the writers when they conceived the
character of Leon the Simpsons is one of
the few successful long-running TV shows
to never have generated a spin-off but
it's not for lack of trying
in 1994 Matt Groening wrote a script for
a new series that bound Krusty the Klown
getting his own talk show and moving to
Los Angeles but it wasn't going to be a
cartoon rainin wanted it to be a
live-action series with Krusty's voice
actor dan Castellaneta reprising his
role in the flesh eventually graining
accepted it had to take the form of an
animated series instead because this
whole thing was just too expensive to
pull off in real life unfortunately the
animated show never saw the light of day
either after negotiations between
graining and Fox stalled but creativity
prevailed Brannan's next project was a
little show about Earth in the year 3000
in late 1988 when the Simpsons was still
just a feature on the Tracey Ullman Show
producers made a deal with Butterfinger
for a commercial featuring Bart Simpson
the script called for Bart to compare
lunches with a friend at school so
Simpsons staff filed through a series of
drawings that graining had done for an
ultimately unproduced NBC Saturday
morning cartoon set in a grade school
the one they picked to use as Bart's
foil was an especially nerdy looking kid
who remained unnamed in the commercial
he needed a name however if he was to
become part of the Simpsons proper is
this the untimely end of Milhouse but
Milhouse is my name what I thought I was
the only one a pain I know all too well
why is he named Milhouse
according to graining I named him
Milhouse because I thought that that was
the most unfortunate name I could think
of for a kid
this is great it only does enter my name
the real house the episode the Itchy and
Scratchy and Poochie show parodied the
once common TV practice of shows
bringing in a cooler younger or
out-of-this-world character to freshen
things up on the Simpsons it's Bart's
beloved itchy and scratchy cartoon which
adds Poochie a sunglasses wearing
rapping surfer voiced by Homer Poochie
ends up a total flop with practically
everyone but Homer seen right through
the cheap ratings ploy the premise is
paralleled in the Simpsons household
which suddenly includes a
never-before-seen sunglasses wearing
dude named Roy who at the end of the
episode moves out good news everybody
I'm moving into my own apartment with
two sexy ladies I guess this is goodbye
Roy Fox had recently tried to do the
same thing to the Simpsons before the
eighth season began Fox executives asked
then showrunners bill Oakley and Josh
Weinstein to add a new fresh face to the
Simpsons family the writers gave them
boy and Poochie instead
as for Poochie well he had the greatest
send-off ever I have to go now my planet
needs me
[Music]